hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice attacking game a lot of you have
requested it's from the vergany cup a
few days ago uh it's from round three
anton korobo versus uh indian
international master from chennai
bharati romanian and it's really a
beautiful uh attacking game uh kodobo of
course is the favorite heroes he's a
very well known uh grand master he
defeated many many strong players but uh
let's see what what young bharata here
has has in store for him because they
play a line that's been played a lot uh
in the past uh especially by some very
strong attackers like alexa shiro for
example and he even finds a nice
improvement on the line so uh let's
check it out quarterback with the white
pieces opens with d4 we have d5 uh c4 e6
and now sorry c6 not e6 c6 that goes for
the slav defense knight to f3 knight to
f6 and the knight the c3 at the three
knights variation of the slav we have e6
going for the semi slav defense and the
bishop to g5
knight b37 and e3 so this is all very
standard stuff it's been played many
many times queen to a5 now putting
pressure on this knight pinning it and
knight to e4 might be an idea and now
knight to d2 is the most common move
here you just unpin your c3 knight and
you take care of the e4 square uh but
kore both trades on d5 first we have
knight captures on the e5 now attacking
the knights twice and queen to d2 we
have bishop to be for adding a third
attacker to the knight and now rook to
c1 and here like i said the position has
been reached before uh alexey shiro for
example enjoyed playing this with the
black pieces but he lost both of his
games um for example to to anand and
arunyan in this position uh but usually
castles or h6 is played here but here we
have knight captures and c3 and this is
a this is a much better attempt as
you'll see b captures on c3 now chasing
back the bishop bishop to a3 attacks the
rook here and rook to b1 uh now it will
be a bit difficult to develop the bishop
as the b7 pawn will be under attack so
b6 now we want to develop the bishop
most probably to the a6 square to trade
off whites a light square bishop that's
usually uh well that usually becomes
very very strong and here there are some
games where bishop to d3 was played but
here korobo plays queen to d3 it's a new
move never been played before so already
as of move 12 we have a completely new
game and it's a very interesting move
because it kind of breaks the principle
of uh you know opening theory but it's
kind of a you know i'm going to step on
this principle in order to
achieve this principle a little bit
better because yes we are still in the
opening and you want to uh improve the
position of your your pieces as much as
possible now the queen on d2 isn't all
that impressive uh attacking this pawn
and this one however uh quarterback
sacrifices one move so he's gonna
develop the bishop a little bit later
but he places the queen on a much nicer
square and now the queen controls both
of these diagonals also okay uh controls
a lot of squares but also controls the
a6 square so black does not have this
bishop to a6 move so let's see how black
continues we have castles and now bishop
to e2 so it's a bit of a more passive
square than d3 for the bishop but it's a
very interesting attempt uh rook to e8
and here quarterback castles and now
bishop back to f8 it's not really doing
all that much here and you're gonna
need it here to to help with the
defense of the of the king's side so
here we have e4 corbeau grabs more space
in the center and it's interesting
according kind of offers the a2 pawn
here but not really if um
if subramanian captures the pawn uh then
he loses the queen rook a1 queen
wherever on the b file rook to b1 and
the queen is trapped there is no way for
you to
get the queen out of there so instead we
have e5 trying to get some traits here
yeah i get the knight
to this active e5 square and now bishop
back to d2 saying okay if captures
captures and my bishop is ready to
attack your queen
and now capturing an a2 is possible but
it is very very complicated i'm just
going to show it to you because i know
you guys are always you know haunted by
these hanging pawns so queen captures an
a2 now knight to g5 already what's
happening here you can see that it's not
pleasant the queen is ready to jump into
action uh what can what can black do
here uh well let's say you go bishop to
a6 you attack the queen and the bishop
and basically you want to give up this
bishop for for the d2 bishop
we're going to play c4 and now
what can black play let's say you try to
chase away the knight a white sacrifices
on f7 but it's not really a sacrifice
because the knight cannot be accepted
and here it's just completely crazy
position that of course
i'm sure both of them uh you know
evaluated uh the problem is if the
knight is captured you have this rook a1
now and now the problem is after queen
captures on c4 you don't have to trade
the king is exposed you simply queen to
f3 check and you pick up the queen
that's it king g8 we're gonna pick up
the queen
captures captures and let's say rook fc
one and the white is just well winning
so instead after bishop to d2 black
doesn't go for the a2 pawn h6 is played
as g5 will be i definitely used by uh
kodobov as an attacking square and now
queen to c4 that nicely placing the
queen on this diagonal uh so here we
have bishop to b7 also the c6 pawn was
attacked so black has to defend it and
now a4 with this a4 pawn uh cordoba
basically traps the black queen on a5
there's really no good square for them
for the queen here and it's interesting
how do you get the queen out of there
black tried rook a to d8 which is a good
attempt but maybe faster was a6 and b5
just trying to
you know get rid of this a4 pawn and
give the queen some breeding room but
rook a to d8 was played we have rook
after e1 and now c5 so this is how black
tries to get the queen back in the game
and also this opens up the light square
bishop's diagonal so queen to b3 very
interesting preparing bishop to c4 as
that f7 pawn is very weak and now bishop
captures an e4 with this a queen to b3
three move quarterback basically
uh leaves the e4 pawn on three but uh uh
all for a very good cause so bishop
captures an e4 bishop to c4 now
attacking the f7 pawn here but also now
korobov gives up the rook on b1
cordova playing in in really beautiful
style here and if black wanted to play
uh some boring defensive game he
probably would have gone bishop to g6
but he accepts kobo's challenge he
captures on b1 uh bishop captures an f7
check king the h8 and now queen captures
on b1 grabbing the
uh grabbing the bishop here also very
interesting was rook captures on b1 uh
kind of to keep the queen stuck here on
a5 and also uh you don't allow rook to
e7 the the queen guards the bishop while
on b3 and then maybe some knight h4 to
g6 uh maneuvers are possible but okay
korobo has a different idea he plays
queen captures on b1 rook the e7 now
trying to chase away the bishop and the
bishop to c4
and now
it's a it's a critical critical moment
in the game black has to play something
like b5 to get the bishop away from this
diagonal uh but e captures on d4 was
played in the game now opening up an
attack towards the rook on e1 but now
knight to h4 going for this knights the
g6 check and look at this all of corvo's
pieces are just attacking that king's
side it it's uh just you know complete
madness here so black captures any one
with check we have queen captures on e1
it's a useful capture as it gets the
queen away from this diagonal now knight
to f6 getting
a piece back into the defense and now c
captures on d4 opening up an attack here
queen captures an a4 and now of course
knight the g6 with check and you can see
that black king only has one square the
bishop still covers the g8 square so
king to h7 was played and it's a really
really wonderful position where uh
korobo basically all of his moves that
led up to this moment and everything was
you know you had to play it with tempo
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it the only move that wins the game
for korobov while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations i'm not playing
something like bishop to d3 or 95 and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course queen
b1 that's the move uh and now there
really isn't all that much you can do
because what are your options uh well
you're obviously threatening some very
nasty discoveries here once the knight
moves so let's try capturing the bishop
just for fun well if the bishop is
captured then comes 95 check and you
lose the queen king to h8 we're gonna
pick up the queen and okay black might
have some counter play after rook
captures on d4 but after queen b3 the
knight is defended the bishop is
defended you don't have b5 because queen
captures uh there's not much
for black to do here it will be
completely winning for white so instead
after queen b1 black tried rook captures
on d4 but now it's actually a forced
checkmate in three and not just any
checkmated the one you've seen in the
thumbnail a nice smuttered one so knight
captures an f8 uh delivering a double
check from the knight end of the queen
king to h8 is the only move now we have
queen the h7 check i know you guys uh
spotted this one miles away uh and now
again the only move available to black
is to capture the queen with the knight
so here knight captures an h7 and now
kobo of course deliver checkmate with
knight to g6 and what a beautiful
checkmate so the bishop that could never
be captured uh prevents the king from
reaching g8 and the knight delivers
checkmate what uh uh what a spectacular
attacking game and you can see how uh
subramanian bharat here uh really uh
played in great style he improved on the
games of uh you know great names like
alexei shirov and he
improved with at night captures on c3
line uh but uh here you can just see
what what uh
you know complete uh a different class
of a player korobo is and whenever he
plays he just creates these uh uh
beautiful masterpieces uh that uh
uh you know we could just uh analyze and
enjoy for days we could only show
quarterback games on this channel for a
month and we would still have a great
time
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it thank you for suggesting
such a nice attacking game uh i would
like to thank thomas vetterli vikinoren
uh martin schweller dylan holloway and
pat kopinger for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that happens in the chess world and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day